ideas have consequences but so does
silence
insist melissa chen the new york editor
for the spectator
and managing director of ideas beyond
borders a non-profit that translates new
and classic
texts about science history and liberal
political philosophy into arabic
and then distributes them free as ebooks
throughout the middle east
born and raised in singapore chen came
to the united states a little bit more
than a decade ago to study genomics at
boston university
she quickly established herself as a foe
of group think
political correctness and cancel culture
in america
while critiquing authoritarian regimes
in china
for birth country and elsewhere a
frequent guest on shows and podcasts
such as the joe rogan experience
bridget fettesey's walk-ins welcome and
the ruben report
chen maintains one of the liveliest
feeds on twitter
mixing long threads with sardonic
comments on the news of the day
chen talks with me today about how an
obsessive focus on identity politics led
the media to keep insisting
without evidence that the murder of
massage parlor workers in atlanta was a
hate crime against asian americans
why hollywood is changing its products
to police sensors in the chinese
government
and how the best way to counter
radicalization
is with speech and information rather
than repression
melissa chen thanks for talking to
reason thank you nick for having me on
let's get right to it uh you have one of
the best twitter feeds in existence
your most recent tweet as of this taping
was
i'd like to welcome the arabs to the
schroedinger's white people's club
signed asians and jews what what do you
mean by that
unpack that for me okay so well
you know um the jews were probably the
first ones to join the club
um many years ago um you know during
i guess like right after the war uh
there were all these like college
admission practices where they were
trying to keep the jews out
and they had quotas so you know jews
were
you know considered people of color they
were
marginalized identities but along the
way you know they became one of the most
successful
immigrant groups and have now are now
considered white
um and it's the same thing with asian
americans
asian americans have you know in the
same way kind of cross that rubicon
and uh well today what happened was you
know there was
um unfortunately just another shooting
in america 10 people were killed
and you know of course you had a lot of
people kind of jumping to conclusions
there were like low resolution images of
the shooter and people assumed he was
white
um a lot of uh sort of our media class
was you know they were tweeting about
how
the very fact that this guy was taken
into custody alive
uh proves that he was white it was just
another white shooter in america
and of course it turned out you know
that he was actually
a muslim american he had very you know
visibly muslim name
um more details came out he turns out to
be syrian
and so there were people trying to
you know kind of uh move the goal post
then instead of
saying you know i was wrong about this
um shouldn't jump to conclusions then
it became well he had white privilege
because he
he looks white arabs are white and
therefore he would you know this is why
he was still taken into custody he
wasn't just shot like he
would have been if he was a you know a
black american
if i'm assuming if the arabs are now
joining the jews as honorary whites the
jews are going to
want to recount or something like that
perhaps yeah
but there is this concept where the the
concept of whiteness is flu
is very fluid you had a ridiculous
headline
in the new york times um a few months
ago about this concept of multi-racial
whiteness this was after
the elections right and and you know one
of the shocking things about the 2020
elections was actually trump
seemed to increase his lead among um
certain minority groups
and that that was a bit of a shock and
so you know you have people kind of
talking about this concept of
multiracial whiteness because whiteness
is such a fluid construct
basically you know whoever they want to
paint and power
is is now considered under this umbrella
and so
you know that was what i was poking fun
at because asians
you know with especially how they have
performed as as a
um as a demographic in in academia
um and also just looking at income like
you know
median wage for example and uh
schrodinger of course is the what uh
physicist who came up with the idea of
you know the
the famous example of a cat being dead
and alive at the same time and
i know i've used it a lot the great uh
schrodinger's immigrant who is
both lazy and comes here to take welfare
or is super energetic and comes here to
steal our jobs like
they can be both it's undecidable they
can be both at the same time right
exactly and that's what we mean by using
these identity groups as
as pawns in in the larger culture war
and we're seeing a lot of that now with
asian americans because on the one hand
you have
universities you know this debate about
universities discriminating against
asians and on the other
suddenly they become minorities when and
it's very useful to the to the narrative
you've written and tweeted a lot about
the um
the impulse among many people to say
that the mass shooting
or spree killing i guess might be a more
technical term
for it in atlanta where you know a a a
man went and shot
eight people uh six of whom were asian
of asian descent and that was
immediately put
into a framework that this is part of
a massive increase in hate crimes
against asians
um it turns out that that may not at all
be the
motivation of the um of the shooter
what you know you you were one of the
first people i saw in press saying you
know what we really need to kind of
think about this
and i think about what the motive is
what was your you know
um why were you so attuned to that um
and why is it
you know why is it important that we
don't jump to conclusions
about why mass killers do what they do
well it's not just mass killers
um you know i said the same thing when
previous uh you know like sort of
previous to this
incident that kind of like rose to the
national consciousness were a lot of
incidents that were happening in
some cities like oakland san francisco
new york because there were actually
video surveillance captured of some
assaults and attacks
of mostly elderly asians and they were
you know perpetrated by
you know quite clearly people that were
not white
and even under those circumstances
people were calling that you know
some you had some conservative outlets
calling it black on asian
crime and i never saw that framing as
useful
um because that it implies something you
know it's you're implying
a certain racial motivation and even
under those situations i said you know i
did tweet that we should actually hold
back
and you know it turns out the d.a
like chesabuddin they did not bring any
hate charges yet
and even under those circumstances i
said we should just wait for
you know these people to be investigated
have their trial play out
figure out if racial motivation really
is
is the reason for this because ambient
crime levels have been increasing
across the board and this is you know
post covet lockdowns um
economic stagnation um and also you have
the confluence of
i guess government ineptitude um there's
a trend where
in some of these progressive cities
where cops have been very reluctant to
prosecute
so a lot of these factors have kind of
come together
and it's caused crime in general to
skyrocket
and so before we jump the gun to say
that this is anything to do with
you know a rise in asian targeted crime
i think it behooves us to see if
that really is the motivation um you
know
through investigations through
interviews with the perpetrators
um because to make this claim is is is
very serious charge
um and you have a press basically that's
very eager to
link trump's rhetoric you know saying
that because of uh he's been very
um you know saying things like kung flu
or
the china virus that this is causing
people
there's a direct line between trump
saying these things
and and you know causing people to
actually act in a way
that's violent towards asians and i
think that's very dangerous and
it has not been proven and moreover
the very fact that this is happening in
um you know
the cities that are didn't didn't vote
for him by a long shot
um is is you know it doesn't seem like a
plausible explanation to me
um you know it's one of the studies that
came out
and i think it was released just a day
or two before the shooting
um but it it purported to show a 150
percent
increase in in 2020 over 2019
in uh hate crimes against asians
um and you know one of the things is
that when you looked at the actual
numbers
it it seemed like there was less going
on than people you know were drawing
from the
the kind of headline conclusion so in
new york city
uh in 2019 they counted three hate
crimes
in uh and then it was something like 23
or 28
in 2020 and you know when you're talking
about a city of 8 million i mean
obviously any of these cri any any
hate crime is one too many but we're not
talking about
thousands or tens of thousands of
incidents um
what i mean you know it's it's an
interesting
i guess kind of conundrum for asian
americans and i
i even bristled you know using that
phrase because i grew up on the east
coast and i didn't remember
people ever saying asian american it was
much it was always
in the same way that europeans were
never called like europeans or whites or
anglo it was always irish
american italian american jewish
american it was korean
japanese chinese whatever you know the
particular ethnicity of the person
um but you know the asian-american
uh you know now seems to um
struggle under the rubri or you know the
moniker of a model minority
is that um you know
is that what gives rise to a need among
asian americans to say hey
we are um you know we're also oppressed
we're also exploited
what do you think is going on there well
i think many
asian americans are you know at this
point
the ones that are highly educated
um there is a certain set of beliefs
that are you know
that are sort of touted in in this
particular class the people that go to
ivy league schools for example
um and you know to to remain on that
cocktail circuit
you know to be invited into
this particular social networks where
people are going to aspen institutes and
all these like fancy places
um a very dominant narrative is is
um critical race theory and and part of
critical race theory
necessarily involves the rejection of
the model minority myth
they keep calling it the myth because
everything is about power and pinning
groups against each other
and that's how they view this that
because
asian americans can be celebrated as a
class as a
as a demographic it puts
other demographics down and
it's it's a bit of an equity kind of um
explanation so you know because
of the implication that okay if to
celebrate this minority group success
means that you're saying that other
minority groups could do better
um and and that is something that that
is completely
frowned upon that is you know um you
shouldn't be pitting these groups
against each other
so that's really kind of where um the
rejection of that
myth comes from and and ironically you
know coming from
the the class of asians that are
highly educated that went to these very
schools that you know
um kind of got in in spite of
affirmative action
and i just actually want to circle back
on something else that you said about
you know you're comparing the statistic
of 150
increase in in hate crimes um just
preliminary police data
um the thing is the fbi doesn't collect
um hate crime
statistics till november so for the last
year you know if we want statistics
from 2020 we'll only get it in november
of this year
so though that data that you're quoting
actually um
is just preliminary and and it's only
been studied
in 16 cities across the united states so
that 150
comes from there now there was another
group that came out um
and because they wanted to track um hate
incidents um in 2020 because this is the
year
of covet lockdown donald trump and and
you had this
activist group it was a new advocacy
group called stop aapi hate
shows up around last year early last
year and they basically built a portal
a web portal where people can go and and
submit
self-report i've just experienced a hate
crime log where it happened
you know kind of describe the incident
categorize the incident
and submit um and so for a while you
were seeing
almost throughout 2020 a statistic that
was um sort of
everywhere quoted everywhere in the
press almost every article talked about
the surge in anti-anti-asian-american
asian-american hate um it seemed like
that was
you know in 1900 it was like a thousand
you know and
and until today so about one year's
worth of collection
there has been 3 800 um hate incidents
and this sounds
terrible like this is like you know it's
like
one hate incident it's enough is enough
but now you have 3 800
incidents um but then you kind of like
look a little closer at the data and you
realize number one
this is not coming from official police
data this is actually
self-reporting anyone can log on in
self-report
number two um this data was actually
also
categorized to show that actually
majority of this wasn't even
violent it wasn't even a physical
incident we're talking about
verbal um incidents we're talking about
shunning like
20 of the the case the hate incident is
actually shunning
so if you've been creating if you've
been kind of fanning these
these flames and getting asian americans
to think that people are out to get them
you know you're walking in a supermarket
and somebody gives you a stare you might
log that
as a shunning incident you know or or
you know this
hostess at a restaurant didn't want to
serve me it could be for any reason but
there's a bit of confirmation bias going
on now because you're actually looking
for it
that's why this narrative is is
dangerous
and and when the media was uncritically
parroting this statistic everywhere
quoting this advocacy group that you
know
sprouted out of nowhere just one year
ago
um i i expected the media to at least be
you know at least put some context at
least mention that in the pieces
but we saw none of that and and you know
by october you had the united nations
writing a report
excoriating donald trump for his
rhetoric and then
you know putting in the report this
exact statistic from the same group
and all of a sudden the next thing you
know the next iteration of the new cycle
became
um the u.n says that asian-american hate
crimes have increased blah blah and this
comes on the heels of donald trump's
rhetoric
so now it has the credibility and
of the united nations and it's just been
quoted as a united nations which
may mean that it has no credibility at
all right i mean that's the upside
but yeah that's that's an amazing um
you know kind of story or thumbnail of
of how
data or factoids you know things that
have the shape of facts get cert
get created and circulated right not
doubting that
there might be an increase in um you
know hate crimes against asian but
but you know the question is really is
it meaningful and has it been tied to
trump's rhetoric and it really looks
like the for the latter question no
whether it's meaningful we really need
to wait till november 2021 to see
whether it is a meaningful rise what has
been your experience and i realized you
know
you you are trained as a scientist um
you know and so i realized that anecdote
isn't data but i saw
again on twitter um you and wesley yang
who's uh
somebody who i uh interviewed here i
don't know like a year and a half ago or
whatever whose book the souls of yellow
folk are
is just a fantastic meditation on all
sorts of things including class and race
and ethnicity in america but
both of you seem to be saying on twitter
that you have not felt
you know a particular spike i because
i've seen a lot of
people of asian descent saying you know
yeah this past year has been pretty
rough
um has but your experience really has
not been that
no not at all um but again i i do think
you know in part when you're primed
to you feel a certain way um you
you can you know interpret a lot of
incidents
as as you know some sort of that has
animosity when it might not have
any um but there's a lot of public
sharing about these kinds of like it's
almost like public therapy
like collective therapy where people
share you know
they're these tweets that they get
thousands of you know retweets and likes
um about incidents like i was at a
grocery store and you know this happened
or
i'm driving around and somebody flashes
a white power sign
and um you know which may or may not be
a white power side right so
i mean the okay kind of yeah yeah
yeah um and you know for for wesley and
i like one of the things we were talking
about
how also is that um when incidents like
that happen all of a sudden you have you
know white friends
or something checking in with you and
asking um how are you
just do you want to talk about something
and you know it's one of those things
where
i almost that makes me feel more asian
than i've
ever felt by checking in with me after
an incident like that it's like
oh right yeah i'm i'm asian you know
how do you conceive of um it's kind of a
weird question but how do you conceive
of asian i mean is that a meaningful
category to you
or or yeah or
do you see yourself i mean you're
originally from singapore
i mean do you see yourself more as
singaporean like i i don't
and i realize this is embedded in the
rhetoric of you know white supremacy
or of whiteness as universal i don't
think of myself as white if i think of
myself in terms of ethnicity i think of
you know i'm irish american or
italian-american i don't think
i'm european but i mean do you see
asian is that like something that's very
big in your head or is it something
different
so i conceive of myself as asian the way
camel
can see himself as black which is
camille foster
camille foster which is this is a
fiction um
and you know in part bring up in
singapore um
help to kind of feed that view because
you know 75 of singaporeans are han
chinese
but we've never you know kind of
identified
with with han chinese because to
create uh you know a very diverse
um country out of four different races
four different religions you had
malays who are muslim indians who are
mostly hindu chinese were mostly
buddhists and then you also had
christians
christians usually eurasians because
there was a lot of intermixing
um and and to you know stuff
these four groups demographics into a
city that
is 360 kilometers square you know in
terms of area
it's basically four times the size of
manhattan just multiply manhattan four
times that's the size of singapore
so you're basically stuffing you know
four million five million of these
people
of all these different races and
religion into into a size
that's basically four times manhattan
and and it's it's a
powder keg right especially as a young
nation so
you know the founder of singapore was
was very careful to
to you know kind of elevate national
identity
because that's how you get people to put
aside their differences
and so the singaporean identity was was
created you know we speak um actually
like a syncretic blend of all four
languages that's
that creates um like a language called
singlish which is kind of a mix of
everything
and so you have a very distinct identity
that was separate from where all these
immigrant groups came from
and in many ways i think it's you know
kind of similar in america right like we
have an american identity it's
it's um it's e pluribus unum right like
from many
one and you create this like one
identity there are these principles and
values and we kind of instinctively
get what it means to be american and
um i think it's the same way in
singapore so it was always clear to me
that
you know that there was no um like what
what is asian like firstly it's a it's a
continent
i mean my my you know my co-founder
faisal he's iraqi he's asian too he's
from the same continent
but we you know the cultures and
backgrounds couldn't be more different
so in a way i
i do see it like the way kamels use it
it's a fiction
and it's it's really meaningless as as a
category
but being singaporean matters to you
doesn't it on some level
um i mean it's just where i was born
there's an accident of
accident of birth um you know and and
the values
what what are the values what would you
say are um
you know the values that are promoted in
a singaporean identity
um very similar to united states uh you
know the idea of meritocracy is very
important
um it's almost enshrined in our national
pledge
because um you know again it's it's you
either have
something merit based or you have
something that is you know
you deserve things because uh either
aristocracy or identity
um and and the only way to kind of
make things fair and ensure that people
have equal opportunity
is to set up a system where you know you
have a meritocracy
um i would say also confusion values are
are very
um uh elevated and so what what does
that mean
um what are confusion values function
values um in the sense of you know
hierarchies are kind of natural um
you you know the nuclear family um is
very important always respect your
elders
um it's more communitarian so you know
things
like um social harmony is kind of prized
against individualism
and that i would say is a bit more is
it's a very clear contrast between what
we have here
um where it is where we're a lot more
individualistic right
we would kind of like um i mean i
wouldn't like it
if anyone tried to justify you know
curtailing of civil liberties
with the argument that oh this is to
preserve social harmony
um so that which i would say is the kind
of major
difference what now when uh when covert
hit
you were um uh you were you were
a critic of a lot of lockdown measures
and you know singapore
was one of the places that was held up
as a model
for how to deal with covet what was
wrong about
uh singapore's model or or was it that
it was
it there was something fundamentally
wrong with it as far as you were
concerned
or it's that it's just fundamentally
antithetical to
how a free society should operate i mean
you know by all accounts and afforded
very well
um and by well they
they didn't manage to keep the cases
very low except for like a flare-up with
um
low-wage blue-collar immigrant workers
which actually the root cause of that
was
stuffing them in these dormitories and
so it really did highlight the foreign
worker
plate in singapore because singapore
like a lot of countries and
you know and arguably the united states
as well there are
there you know there is a group of
people who don't who weren't born there
who come there and labor there and do a
lot of the grunt work
and are kind of segregated out of
regular society and so in singapore
these people don't
have access to the same social welfare
benefits or citizenship or
anything and a path to citizenship
unless maybe
a local um but yes they really shine the
spotlight on this kind of like
two-tiered system right and on parallel
worlds where
um these workers actually you know have
you know are paid really low wages and
and so it was good that it kind of
sparked that conversation and i think
that it that you know what happened
it will improve their their um their
prospects
but um by all accounts other than that
when singapore did
you know perform really well by by all
by most measures
and you know they never really had to
lock down schools the way we did
um but here is what happens if let's say
i
or you wanted to travel to singapore you
would have to be quarantined
in an airport for two weeks so they shut
down the borders
and was a mandatory quarantine um you
would be tracked
and if you were found to have violated
your your quarantine as
a american fedex pilot discovered he
basically
left his quarantine i think half an hour
earlier to pick up some drugs at the
pharmacy before his flight back to the
united states
he got arrested and he was jailed for
two days um
the you know it's from our perspective
something like that would be
ridiculous to jail somebody for breaking
a quarantine half an hour early
we're not even enforcing our quarantines
right so even domestic travel we've not
even been enforcing it
but you know the singapore mindset has
always been to
um sort of enact
certain punishments to make an example
out of people because these examples
then become
turns for other kinds of behavior and
um in a way that's actually a very kind
of like
tiger mom asian kind of mindset we have
to
you know make an example out of you and
so i think that's why you had such harsh
punishments
and then they also started creating
these apps um to allow tracking
and i think one of my criticisms of it
was actually that um you know
the the government basically said don't
worry this app is just to you know
track the spread of code um but of
course
it was used actually and some data was
turned into the police who used it to
arrest two individuals so it's the
classic slippery slope
um kind of problem that we worry about
came to fruition
um otherwise you know i think
it's it's a totally different country
with
very different ideals and at the end of
the day they didn't have to shut down
their schools um businesses were
actually open for a much longer time
um and it it it remains to be seen
you know which which methods was
you know better yeah and it's also it's
not clear that we had to shut down right
i mean
large you know shutting down the schools
seems to have been a
complete waste of time and resources
with uh probably very long-lived
ramifications that
we can barely begin to conceptualize for
the moment
um so uh you you uh came over to the
united states from singapore
in order to study and you were studying
genomics
why did you come here and has the
country
paid off for you in the way that you
hoped it would
um i decided to come here because
um you know singapore's always like
obviously kind of
a very socially repressive place if
you're
a natural rebel which i was
um it was i i i knew i needed to leave
to at least live a portion of my life
outside the country
um and you know the united states for me
was the first choice obviously
it appealed to me because of some values
that were in direct opposition to
you know the the values that i grew up
with in singapore
um the freedom of speech was very
important i was so
aware of of these what we would call
ob markers out of bounds markers
um and you know when you have a law that
would penalize
people for speech that could be you know
that
basically if you offend the religious
feelings of a certain
group you could be jailed as as has
happened
um it it really puts a damper on
on speech in the sense of
self-censorship so people do end up
self-censoring
and you just feel like there's this
general sense of you're you're walking
on eggshells all the time
um but in one way it's it's just very
clear if you don't talk about race or
criticizing going too much or
talk about the legal system you'll be
fine and and you know you kind of knew
that you just
as long as you didn't go there you're
okay but
it does have an overall effect on on
people
and um i i was always kind of a
rebellious
kid anyway and you know coming to the
united states was it was a bit
was quite important to me um and i
imagine that you know
in college it would you know we'd be
free to discuss anything
and and uh of course yeah you really
picked the wrong time to come to the
united states
i picked the right time by the time i
graduated 2009. so
that was before um it was really only
later on and i was actually working on
campus at the time
um that i started to see all the
shenanigans
and you know that was like i was
probably one of the first ones to start
speaking out about it because i
could sense i think people that live in
countries where
where speeches were pressed tend to have
a particular sensitivity to it it's like
our antenna like oops
something's wrong you have the kids here
who these are supposed to be your
educator class they're going to be the
elites of your entire cohort and they're
the ones clamoring for censorship
they're the ones displaying this
uber sensitivity to everything i wanted
to shut
you know shut speech down disinvite
speakers and that's when i
i i realized like something is wrong
with america but in speaking out
you know one of the one of the pushbacks
that i got was
he this is kind of fine too this is just
fringe don't worry it's a
phase they're just crazy college
students this will never
survive contact with reality after they
graduated
uh six years into it right maybe this is
like
2014. um you know that that was wrong
yeah um okay so two questions and first
um you know you said you were kind of a
born
rebel or individualist or whatever do
you think it's really temperamental like
that
or were there particular experiences or
books that you read because
we're going to talk about ideas beyond
borders which translates books
uh kind of western enlightenment type
books
secular books into arabic and then
distributes them in in the arab speaking
world
um so you're exporting your
troublemaking even more than you
might have been just by walking around
singapore but you know was
is it is it really just a kind of
temperament or is it
something that you think was learned uh
by you from either the things you read
or the experiences you have
oh i'm sure i'm sure it's a it's a it's
a mix of all things
um but you know i i grew up into a very
um
i guess my my mom was methodist and so i
was sent to you know protestant schools
my whole life
and very active she was very active in
church
um and i definitely remember questioning
a lot of the uh
sunday school teachers you know um even
when i was six or seven to the point
that i had to get out of class
um and other kids who grew up
you know in the same social milieu um
would just sit there and just kind of go
along with it
i never really could get into religion
and i tried
and i knew that speaking up was a bit of
a you know it's a it's a kind of culture
where where even just asking
questions was frowned upon because you
know part of confusion values is there's
hierarchy you should always respect your
teacher
and and information flow is top down not
bottom up
and and that's one of the bigger
contrasts with america when i came here
for college i'm like you mean you can
talk back to the professor you mean this
is a discussion i mean it
was mind-blowing it just was the total
culture shock
um you mean i can call the professor by
his first name i didn't have to like you
know sir or madam
it's it's such a different unless it's
dr jill biden
you know you can just call them jill or
you know bill or whatever
um you know it's fascinating to think
about uh you know
introducing uh protestantism protestant
christianity
into an asian culture or in you know
into a catholic culture in europe in the
you know in the uh 17th uh you know uh
16th 17th 18th centuries where there's
such
a um you know premium in protestant
theology in individual experience
individual interpretation
um you know that it it seems like a bad
idea to
you know be you know introducing
christianity into
asian settings if if what you want is to
maintain hierarchy
actually is doing so well so you know
the the country with
the largest number proportion-wise of
christians actually going to be china
in the mix by 2025 um look at mega
churches in korea you know
it's it's huge in asia christianity is
booming there
and it's booming as it is on the decline
um here in the west in general
what explains that is it uh you know
that they you know that it's actually
true and people are going to be
you know they're banking on being saved
or what is appealing about christianity
in
you know communist china um no it's not
really necessarily communist china i
think uh culturally
you know the um sort of i think both
christianity and and values like asian
values which i really don't like that
term
um they there's something that goes kind
of hand in hand
this like work ethic christian ethic um
the uh very the simplicity of seeing the
world
you know with like good and evil and
salvation
it's it appeals to the asian mindset
very much
um and then also christianity is very
focused on on
the nuclear family and and social
conservatism
and asians are social conservatives um
you know and it's one of the
the reasons why many of them you know
are vote for
republicans so my other question was
when you started to encounter in an
american context
students being the ones who are saying
like hey you know don't ask
questions or don't don't make statements
that are kind of upsetting to people
where do you think that's coming from um
because
you know it used to be the ideas that
you would go to college and you know
this
is mythologize and romanticize it but
the idea was you would go to college in
order
to be offended or to be exposed to
things that you couldn't possibly
believe are true
and you would have long late night
conversations you know
arguing about everything um and that
seems to
not be you know what the dream is
anymore what you know what
what's going on with the new kind of um
repression on campuses i i quite fully
buy
into george lucano's work uh and
jonathan height with uh coddling of the
american mind
um and i think this concept of safetyism
is really coming from the kind of
of a parenting for over a few decades
that have led up to this point
so you're indicting me and my parenting
point taken
you know i offered no defense but i mean
think about how different america would
be if if we were all brought up by
amichua
we would be able to take a lot um it's
you know okay maybe that was extreme but
but there is a sense that that kind of
parenting is not
really incalculating a sense of
resilience emotional clients to things
um and and we're so you know we're
creating a generation that that's just
used to having their feelings validated
all the time
you could be anything participation
trophy for you
um you know and and in fact that you
know in part that's a bit of a lie right
like we tell
these kids all the time you can be
anything you want and it's great it's in
fact i mean you know
liberalism was great coming from a
conservative society where
you know you're told no you can't be
anything you want it's not you do you
you know basically you're half available
to you is pretty constrained
if if not singapore itself in a lot of
countries where it's like
at a certain age you take an exam and if
you don't make a certain score then
you know whole swaths of the future are
just blocked off to you i mean
that's a terrible world to live in it
i i fully believe it's terrible but
there is a dark side to the american
method i think and and we're starting to
to feel it i
you know a lot of kids are not given
that dose of reality they're
you know if you're told for your whole
life that you'll be anything by the time
you hit
college and your options start doing
knowing
you start to see your own limitations um
all of a sudden it hits you you're like
wait a minute maybe i can't do anything
and that you know
dissidence that that existential crisis
it creates is
um it can be pretty damaging
so uh let's talk about ideas beyond
borders the
organization you co-founded with uh
faizal matar
uh matar um what is ideas beyond borders
and why why does why is it necessary to
to exist um you know it's a
organization that you know my co-founder
who is from iraq
um we we started to really fill a role
we wanted to
plug a gap in
in knowledge and expose um you know
people that
speak arabic to ideas that that were
just not really available in that
language
mostly because you know a lot of these
books are just not translated
um and and the translations are hard
they're not economically feasible the
bookmark book markets publishing markets
in
most in most arabic countries arabic
speaking countries are actually not
robust i always give this statistic just
just for people have an idea
a new york times best seller here in the
united states you would need to sell
about 5 000 copies
in one week i'm an arab bestseller it
will be
you know a book that sells five thousand
copies in an entire year
so and and uh we wanted to kind of
change that
um there were a lot of books that we
thought should exist in arabic that we
should
you know have people access the you know
be given free access to
um that were ideas about uh books about
the enlightenment
um you know we actually just did uh
translating
um john stuart mills on liberty the
graphic novel
into arabic um you know we've done we're
doing science books books about
philosophy
um just to kind of reignite this um
uh culture of reading there was a time
when when the
arabic speaking world was actually you
know very pluralistic
scholars used to go there there were
libraries everywhere
and it's changed um you know and it
never really bounces is that
mostly is that is that largely in your
understanding is that largely a function
of
political ideology merging with religion
or i know that you guys
focus some attention on the idea of
secularism
um as something that has gone missing
but it's also i was talking to
a woman who i guess was syrian and
was talking about how um in the 60s you
know women were wearing miniskirts and
going to university in many ways it was
as or more advanced
many parts of the arab world than you
know then the west
so is it is it simply um
islam or is it also islam plus kind of
nationalism or
pan national definitely the latter
i think islam was co-opted in a way
um to shore up power you know i mean
saddam
everyone you know people like oh sadam
was a secular guy you know
and and kind of pit him against
al-qaeda contrasted him with al-qaeda
and isis who are explicitly religious
fanatics
but saddam used religion saddam co-opted
it
to shore up power and in fact by
you know killing all the moderates
killing all the liberals he created a
vacuum
for these islamist groups to thrive
and he you know just like them didn't
tolerate
there was no you know toleration of
dissent uh toleration of
minorities of different viewpoints so it
they were kind of a manifestation of the
same
intolerance what are what's uh you know
how many people have you reached
how do you measure the reach of ideas
beyond borders
um and generally you translate the books
and i i know i've talked to faisal about
this i mean it's
it's pretty stunning and inspiring you
get
you know people generally who live in
that part of the world to
translate books at you know real
personal risk if they're on mass but
then you circulate them as pdfs or as
moby files and things like that but
what's
you know what's the what's it what's a
hit for you or what is the reach of your
operation
um so a book like stephen pinker's
initially like enlightenment now it's
very thick so that took a long time to
translate
um a book like his got 12 000 downloads
in the first six months just from our
website alone and that's what we can
track
but in the middle east books are
actually shared a lot
via telegram so there are these big
channels where you have almost
a black market of books and so you would
have something like richard dawkins
book the god delusion about atheism
translated into arabic and
shared in these telegram channels now
once it's in telegram we can't track it
so we don't know how far these books
really go and frankly we don't care the
whole idea is to get it far and wide
um i would say we pivoted to wikipedia
also because
you know when you're translating with
wikipedia this is all common
licensing so we don't have to worry
about
one of the major bottlenecks of this
entire process
is negotiating with publishers and the
copyright holders
getting the contracts i mean there was a
point when faizon and i were thinking
ourselves why hadn't this been done
before
you know it's a slam dunk idea like
obviously has to be done
well there's always the reason why it
hasn't been done before
um you're not you're never the first
person to think about something
uh and and it's because it was hard and
it was hard to negotiate with his rights
um it's kind of stunning though people
like stephen pinker and sam harris and
others
i guess dawkins as well kind of gave you
the rights in arabic
right i mean and i guess in a way it's
like the the market is so small it's
you know in a way it's you know it's
easy to be generous with them but it's
pretty stunning that they were just like
yeah
take them and do that exactly they're
very generous of them and of course they
could there is some reality to be made
i will say that that one of the most
stunning turnarounds is actually
a few publishers at the baghdad book
fair approached us and said they
actually wanted to uh you know
publish in print sam had two of sam
harris's books in one of stephen
pinker's books and we were
actually surprised because you know for
a publisher to
display such a book and have this book
as
on their shelves it is a very big
undertaking and the fact that
we actually you know we're moving from
the digital world to getting printed
copies of these books
being sold in the country like this is
the kind of change that we were hoping
to see
and um it's it was it's very heartening
um you know and like you mentioned
the translators that work for us we have
120 of them all across
you know from syria to jordan to egypt
um these people are so inspiring they're
mostly very young
university educated and they're very
interested in
science one of our translators who's
been targeted the most
works a lot on evolution and and that is
a very controversial topic
um he got some uh thankfully it's
settled dogma in the united states right
i mean at least several of the
republican presidential candidates say
they believe in evolution
so you know we're making real progress
well
that's not a lightning rod anymore you
know what just to be having these
debates about
teach the controversy teach you and that
seems to have all faded away
yeah um you know you you've written a
lot about
you know or as as we're talking about
all sorts of things you know and there's
a
horrific violent crime in the united
states and there's a kind of shutdown of
certain types of speech
uh you know what's permissible in uh you
know in public spaces
in another way you know it's also true
that you know we live in the golden age
of speech and expression everybody can
say whatever the hell they want which is
great
but then you've written about um hong
kong uh you know which is still
you know uh fighting you know with with
uh the chinese communist party
are you optimistic about the middle east
about the arab-speaking middle east are
you
optimistic about china and the way that
it is dealing with places like hong kong
as well as the countries in its
most obvious sphere of influence um or
do you think
you know the world is becoming darker if
if i kind of focus
just on you know what i what i see with
the trends of the youth and everything
in the middle east it seems optimistic
many of them have seen you know rotation
they've seen secular you know dictators
um
authoritarian governments they've seen
the their societies collapse
terrorism um islamist group so
many young arabs actually reject
all of this they're almost you know i i
think this is a breeding ground for
libertarians
the entire region i thought you were
going to say they're nihilus
and hence of natural libertarians but no
but
i mean so they're kind of post um
totalizing ideologies at this point
whether it's
a secular tyranny or a religious tyranny
yeah because all of them have
brought you know have brought nothing
and and just death
and and chaos to their countries um
and uh but my my main concern
is actually the rise of you know uh an
authoritarian ethno state that
that is a lot that is exporting their
censorship
apparatus they're exporting it to the
middle east
um that you know china has also begun
putting out um their state uh state
television cgn tv
uh sinha news agency has uh both of
these
outlets have arabic channels where you
have like
um you know an asian girl like speaking
perfect arabic perfect accent um
and you know during covet a lot of these
channels were actually spreading
misinformation there was they were
spreading ideas about
um this virus having been invented by
the cia or in
a u.s lab and being released in china
here's the proof
um and so you have you know
china basically winning these arab
countries over
also by soft diplomacy um by the belt
and wrote initiative
you know i think it was very telling
that majority muslim countries
in the arab world did not sign
the letter condemning china to the
united nations
for their treatment of the muslims the
uyghur muslims
in xinjiang and again that has all to do
with with market access
and you know the the quid pro quo that
that china has
provided these countries in the form of
infrastructure
they've signed deals with saudi arabia
for you know infrastructure spending and
things like that so
it's it's very worrying uh you have uh
written and spoken about the way that
china is corrupting hollywood or you
know
us-based entertainment companies can you
talk about
you know what what forms is that taking
i think all of us were familiar with the
the kind of brouhaha over the
live-action version of mulan
uh whereas you know a cast of thousands
kind of and it's like yes uyghurs
in concentration camps but um can you
talk a little bit about your
uh you know what what the chinese
government is doing and why it concerns
you
um you know there's been quite a few
movies that that it
that it has impacted um almost there are
almost no hollywood movies today
major productions that that are not
financed by china
there was a certain point i think if you
look at the james bond
films um there was one with the movies
that
featured uh north koreans as
the enemy i can't remember one of the
pierced boston ones
that was actually supposed to have been
china
like chinese individuals were you know
where the general was like
the enemy that james bond tried to take
down
um but china was able to pressure
the rewriting of the scripts to you know
instead have it be a north korean
general instead so they've actively
um gone into you know if tibet was an
issue
you know to erase that so if if the
script called for a tibetan monk as it
did in dr
dr strange yeah by the way an actual
medical doctor not a phd
just dr stratton just like you actually
uh well now i
am uh i am a phd but not a medical
doctor
and so when i offer medical advice
really don't take it
but yes so and i mean what what
what is the solution or what you know
what kind of what is your solution to
that because on a certain level what
hollywood is doing you know hollywood
has a shorthand for this
because it also extends to the nba uh
you know where
you know within the same week you might
have somebody like lebron james
you know talking about uh you know
rightly criticizing certain types of
police tactics in the united states but
then shutting down
fellow players for daring to say
anything bad about china
um you know what you know what is the
right way to do that because on a
certain level these giant corporations
whether it's a movie studio or a
you know a sports league they're just
going where the money is right
right i mean i i think there's a
difference between
you know companies that are involved in
the national security infrastructure
um for for those companies anybody
that's providing some sort of
electronics to
say the electrical grid yeah i think we
have to be very careful about
about working with any any company
really you know that has relationships
with china
chinese companies do not have any
separation
there's there's this thing called a
civil military fusion
um every company has to have a on their
board um a member of the communist party
so it's not like in the united states
where there is actually a wall of
separation between industry and state in
in china they are one in the same
so any you know note that passes through
uh china if your company is hosting a
server there
you can almost bet your you know entire
company's assets uh that on the fact
that
you will be spied on um and
so i think the policies regarding these
kinds of you know companies are very
different
than entertainment than the nba
where we we can't stop this from
happening there's there's no law
you know that this is not something that
we we can pass by legislation
but i do think that people speaking up
about it people pointing out the
hypocrisy
at some point it has to be so obvious
that that you cannot take this public
position because it is
simply embarrassing um and so you know
there
are some you know liberal talk show
hosts that that have been highlighting
this bill maher is a very good example
of one
um and uh the more this kind of
penetrates the public consciousness
organizers we need to have people that
um you know bring together
uh people in hollywood directors
whatever to talk about the problems
they're facing
with um you know people who journalists
who study this problem who know exactly
what's going in xinjiang
um and and kind of bring them together
to talk because i think
a big part of this is you know for a
long time i think it was naivete it was
just
you can make money we can all make money
we can get rich together china will
change
clearly that you know the opposite has
happened china is not only not changing
but they are changing us
um yeah can we talk about that a little
bit because
yeah there was that moment and i'm
thinking back to like the early youtube
days when
you know you would see videos and this
was kind of a paradigmatic youtube video
and it made you know i think about it i
i
kind of choke up a little bit but it
would be chinese kids
singing or lip-syncing backstreet boy
songs wearing kobe bryant lakers jerseys
and it was like okay you know what
uh america or the west has tried you
know military power and that's become a
crop or it's just you know
destroyed all sorts of things including
uh the economies of
of the west and that you know we were
all going to be able to communicate
you know uh through uh shared
entertainment and culture
and and things like that um that has
really kind of disappeared and we now
you know seem to be in a place where
it's like no it's just you know one
one uh popular line of thought
is you know that china is just becoming
is rising and is dominant
milton friedman back in the 70s and
in his 1980 mini-series
for pbs free to choose talked a lot
about how
um you know he believed that economic
freedom
um you know allowed when if you if it
gave people economic freedom they became
richer when they became richer
they started to demand political freedom
um
and then as the 80s unfolded he seemed
to be absolutely right that what was
happening in china
you know the after mao died the economy
was liberalized
people got wealthier the tmn square the
democracy movement
uh you know kind of rose and then it was
crushed
um do you think he was hopelessly naive
that a rising standard of living um
is ultimately going to force a political
uh
you know a kind of political freedom
that is now maybe unimaginable in china
or um you know or is it just that his
timeline was off and that it it'll come
down the road
it's funny because i i remember this
narrative and obviously it's reinforced
by
uh you know the end of history right
yeah it's
yeah they're all part of the same kind
of big story yes
but the reason i never bought it was
because i was from a country that
proved that that was wrong right
singapore
went through was one of the first asian
tigers
and you know it went from it went to
first world in like
a few decades um and i remember uh you
know by by most accounting was doing
very well on gdp per capita
people were surprised at this country
and how it really punched above its
weight
it was by all accounts a very prosperous
nation
and it got there in a very you know
quick amount of time well
i didn't notice that people were um
were demanding for more political
freedoms they were actually very
satisfied and it's one of the things
that bothered me about living there
you know um i was very bothered by the
fact that it was
2010 and we still didn't have gay rights
we still
had the on the books a part of the law
that criminalizes homosexuality on the
books
and and i could see that people were
very happy with the government
and realized that if as long as it was
prosperous
as long as their you know mass hierarchy
of needs were met
most people didn't need the
self-actualization most people didn't
need that at all
and you know the gulf states also were
kind of going down the same route where
they were getting very wealthy
um mostly oil money sovereign wealth
funds were swelling but
people weren't trying to change and call
for change in terms of
more political rights um you know
liberalization of social norms
they were kind of static and so i i kind
of had a sense something was wrong with
that
that thesis but you know
the one thing that um i kind of think
that was
it's unfair to judge milton friedman for
is
in china's case it's not a really fair
assessment because china never really
had
a two-way street in terms of
communication
so they had this big firewall and as
they grew
um they were able to keep their own
population in the dark
now if if those walls were were taken
down
if if you know we could if the average
chinese person could read everything
about the world from the comforts of
their own home and learn about the world
that way
maybe they would have made you know they
would have actually demanded for more
political freedoms
well do you think it's likely i mean is
it likely that
the you know chinese government will
really be able to maintain
you know a strict kind of firewall or
you know
is is it already happening that you know
this
you just can't keep the world out for
too long especially the more you trade
with it even if it's under very
constrained circumstances
that's what we thought right but the way
technology has gone
is actually it's reinforcing the
surveillance state
it's actually shoring up their
authoritarian power in a way that's
almost unprecedented
um you know that there's an amazing
article the atlantic
the panopticon is already here about how
they're deploying that
in xinjiang and whatever you're seeing
in xinjiang you know that's going to be
deployed for the rest of the country
this social system this is
a broad social credit system where
everything you do
kind of gets tracked and it may be i
mean there may be a state
version of that and there may be a kind
of private sector version of that coming
in america you've written
uh one of the stories that you wrote for
spectator usa
um was about how um
yelp is starting to add certain elements
of a kind of social credit system to it
right could you talk a little bit about
that
um yeah i i think that was uh with
regard i can't remember what the
what the story was about like it was it
was about um
like race racists um
or racially charged behavior was noted
at a restaurant or something like that
that they had a tag
yes and and there have been a few cases
of this nationally where
um you know a owner an owner i think you
know one
in one case there was a um a white woman
who started a chinese restaurant
and she uh declared that this was like a
healthy version of chinese food you know
cleaned
used the word clean eating in her
instagram post to promote the restaurant
and and people jumped on that and said
wait are you saying that chinese food is
dirty
you know you you must be racist and
anyway a white woman starting a chinese
restaurant is problematic or something
to that of that sort um and so she you
know the
the review system yelp review systems
were actually weaponized
um it became a a frontier for
for the people accusing her racism and
and
and um you know when yelp starts
saying as a policy we're going to
actually note
when a restaurant has been accused of
racism um this is like
saying all right we're just gonna have
profiles for everybody we're gonna note
when somebody is accused of me too
accused and just have that label in
their profile and it's gonna stick
um what could go wrong i mean this is
you know mob rush to judgment on
steroids
and it's going to follow you i mean
europe is slightly better at this i
think they have things like the right to
be forgotten
and they they care a little bit more
about privacy um
but although they also care a lot more
about controlling
expression right so that certain kinds
of uh
thoughts or words are verboten you can't
buy and sell certain things
as as a final point and i'm going to
mangle the
the pronunciation because i think it's
latin
and even though i took two years of
latin in high school i have no idea how
to
pronounce it uh on your twitter feed
which is
uh ms mel chen and there'll be links
to uh this at the reason page for those
who are listening
you uh have a slogan that is keper
aude c-a-p-e-r-e-a-u-d-e
do you remember what that is and why is
that important
yes um my latin is also bad but
thankfully
uh you know that's it's not a
microaggression of mispronounced land
yeah not anymore right because italians
italians kind of became white along
you know about you know when joe
dimaggio went hit in 56 games in a row
italians became white except for the new
jersey one like
that's they're they're the worst they're
garbage yes
so what does compare i would mean up
here i think it's up here
odd s-a-b-r-e um
it translates to dare to know and it
was kind of seen as the motto
of the enlightenment period and i've
always kind of identified with that
phrase because
um you know the idea about daring to
know something know something that is
forbidden knows something that is
you know knowledge that was kept because
at the time during the enlightenment it
was controlled by the church
and the church was the one censoring all
other publications and
poor voltaire had to be exiled
and you had to meet in these secret
salons to discuss ideas and
you know the entire encyclopedia by um
uh dietero was published in secret
and i've always identified with that
because i think um
you know like this idea that uh right
now we
are kind of living in that culture again
where where where
you know there are certain certain ideas
that we're not allowed to kind of talk
about in public not because of
government censorship but because
um you know of certain social more it's
like questioning certain
ideas um maybe even putting out data you
know we you have people
fired for just quoting statistics that
were coming out from academic journals
um
and you know it's not about it's not
about knowing all the answers right it's
the the most important thing in life is
knowing that you can ask questions that
lead to the answers
and we now live in a time where even
questions cannot really been
be asked comfortably about certain
topics
um and so i kind of like use that phrase
to to remind myself of not
you know don't be afraid don't be afraid
to ask because
having all the questions is actually
more important than having all the
answers
all right that's a great note to end um
we're going to leave it here we've been
talking with melissa chen she's the
managing director of ideas beyond
borders
she's a columnist that's the spectator
usa
and you can find her on twitter
clubhouse and virtually every social
media platform
melissa thanks for talking to reason
thank you nick